hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to berry now it's story
time again because I just couldn't help
but dive deeper because we were just
scratching the surface of what the hell
is going on in this forest and does this
have something to do with some sort of
containment system for abnormal entities
of some sort so I just had to make
another episode of it so get headphones
on and crank up the volume is going to
be a wild ride we're standing on the
thin platform of what looks like a fancy
subway the rails look well used but not
old they're small overhead lights that
are very dim as if they're running on
emergency power the dim overhead lights
are a blessing but the size of the place
makes me feel vulnerable staring ahead
the tunnel seems to be endless it's
almost dizzying but there's a small
light further ahead and then a space
that breaks the monotony of the tunnels
curved surface another platform maybe
why are we in a subway Dennis what do
you think of this yeah Dennis seems to
know a bit it's something that he's not
telling me
looks like we're waiting for the D train
then it says with the deadly sounding
cackle also the ringing noise is louder
down here it's much more solid now that
some of the sound something like the
faint hum of machinery what's your take
on this boss you think we're safe down
here not at all is what I think to
myself but I don't want to let Dennis
see that I'm rattled well he seems to be
limping along much better than we first
stumbled into this place he's still in
rough shape I'm leading him here I
should probably make him feel confident
in that I'm not sure this is creepy yeah
we'll be fine you know I want to
reassure him that we're going in the
right direction I mean why wouldn't we
be fine the abnormal entity is on the
outside of the building not in with us
you reassured Dennis we're too far in to
go back besides if we get caught for
trespassing I'm pretty sure we'd slide
by we're good you're in pain we've got
to find the rest of our crew they could
still be here somewhere
then it's nods and look reassured I'll
be weak and miserable from the looks of
it we can go either right or left the
left slightly lit but the right not so
much this makes me uneasy because I get
the sense that one wrong turn in a place
like this would have us wandering for
hours suddenly I jerked my head to the
right as I hear the unmistakable sound
of someone
walking did you hear something I Stannis
Maya straining to see if anything in the
darkness not sure maybe it sounded like
footsteps a wait a moment but the sound
doesn't come again so those are our
options to the left are flickering rides
indicating that will at least be able to
see there's also a hum of machinery a
sign of life to the right is just
darkness but we also heard footsteps in
that direction you know what that may
seem spooky but footsteps literally
footsteps means it can't be that
monstrous and maybe they're just scared
because they hear people talking so
let's go right you decided to go into
the darkness maybe not a good idea but
here we go
if there's anyone here they're worth
speaking to right it is yeah I mean
honestly we're looking for help we're
looking for anything we need someone to
talk to and if there's someone here that
I want to find them there could be our
crew as we leave the glow of electric
lights things instantly start to feel
bit more sinister I look at Dennis's
injuries again the gas along his side is
inflamed now and while the bleeding
seems to have stopped the amount that is
sucked into his pants insured is beyond
alarming how much further can you walk
can you keep going yeah let's walk into
the deep dark tunnel that it's no
business being here he's right the
darkness we find ourselves in feels
thick like walking in ceará I'm reminded
of the fear I felt as a child when I had
to go into the basement to fetch tools
from my dad I was sure there were snakes
or spiders or monsters of unimaginable
horror
lurking down there I feel that same way
walking here through the tunnel that's
when I see a human figure far in the
back of the tunnel silhouetted in the
faint light at the end he's standing on
some other platform ahead up ahead and
likely can't see us it looks like he
might be holding a gun but it's too dark
to be sure yeah you know
there's a risk in calling out to them
but at the same time if they hear a
human voice why would they shoot first
why would they shoot first why would
they why would they shoot for might be
holding again I'm willing to bet that
it's something else ah yeah why not hey
who's there I'm willing to trust my
voice echoes through the tunnel bouncing
endlessly off the falls the figure turns
towards us and freezes like a deer
sensing danger
how did you do that we don't know who
that is we don't know where we are I
don't know maybe you can answer some
questions but that doesn't happen the
person can't see us in the dark and
after a moment the figure rushes away
through a door up ahead well at least he
didn't shoot us so that's kind of a good
thing
I mean he's scared for a reason but why
was he standing alone on the platform
anyway very confused as we head further
into the tunnel we reach another
platform this lights coming from the
platform but like the overhead lights
their dim red emergency lights I start
to wonder if the explosions the longing
sight caused the power outage in this
place whatever this place is the
bringing noise that I originally thought
was in my head is getting louder I'm
starting to think it's some sort of
alarm when we come to the large open
area ahead in the tunnel and further
resembles a subway station as much as I
try to ignore the reality undeniable we
stumbled into some sort of high-tech
transportation system that is buried
beneath the forests of Kentucky makes
absolutely no sense and create an
entirely new sort of fear as to what the
hell we've walked into I noticed that
Dennis seems confident though when we
reach the large opening we have to climb
over the rails up onto the platform I
have to help Dennis over the rails but
then up to the small utility ladder that
is bolted into the opposite side of the
travel way when he reaches the large
opening area resembling a subway waiting
area he collapses on the floor and lets
out a heaving breast you know what this
is ridiculous I quit I'm not going any
further on top of worrying about my crew
and the madness of where we are I'm not
in the mood for Dennis to act like a
baby I don't think that is going to
respond well to harsh criticism he seems
to respond to reassurance we can do this
Dennis we can do this I'm not the one
with the gash in my side I think to
myself so I decided to cut him some
slack damn boss
I'm sorry it's okay I don't know how
you're still on your feet if I'm being
honest stubbornness he says with a weak
laugh you need am in distress
I asked us warmly as I can muster now if
I sit down to rest I'm afraid I might
not get back up I'll keep going while I
can still go I reached down to help him
to his feet and then we get ourselves up
on the platform right in front of us
there's an entrance to a long hallway
exiting the platform area it's at this
point that I realized these red
emergency lights might be on for someone
else who is actually supposed to be here
like that guy I saw earlier standing on
the platform like yell out or do I stay
quiet well I mean I've been yelling
non-stop thus far so might as well
announced by presents to all here I
don't know what's the harm in yelling we
need help we do we desperately need help
I know it's not the smartest idea hello
anyone here there's not much of an echo
my voice falls flat like a rock from the
sky I'm most glad that I didn't get an
answer
hearing anything else in this Hall of
silence would have given me a heart
attack the emergency lights continue to
flicker overhead casting a sixth sort of
pinkish light on everything my mind is
racing with what sort of places might be
Xavi said it's meant to be a secret and
if it is supposed to be a secret there
was a power outage recently maybe most
everyone has been evacuated and then why
was that one person still here this fog
does nothing to make me feel any better
as we walk towards the platforming we
step inside and it seems just as empty
as every other place we come through
weakly illuminated by more overhead
lights we're standing inside a hallway
that looks surreal for a moment maybe
was a good idea maybe it wasn't I have
no idea the hallway reminds me of a
hospital wait that's something not quite
right about it it's the first clean and
tidy area I've seen since coming into
the woods it looks like it was recently
in use despite the dim emergency lights
overhead there are chairs against the
walls in the floor looks well clean this
through the wall the ringing noise is
definitely coming from here and a small
fraction red light along the ceiling
seems to flash along with it that
ringing noise is an alarm I say only to
confirm my own thoughts but for what
Denis asks and then he asked a question
that has been on my mind since I found
the little building in the woods what
the hell is this place
we exchanged a look that speaks volumes
we reach the end of the hallway and hear
a sound like a large metallic grinding
is followed by clicking noise and then
the unmistakable noise of a generator
kicking on whose power back has power
been restored okay without a warning the
facility jolts to life the red glow of
emergency lights is suddenly replaced by
a bright white fluorescent one the
mechanical hum is oddly comforting
somehow the power being act back on
urges us on it's then that I notice the
bringing noise has stopped so it had
been in war for what just for the power
failure we had done the hallway the
electric hum of the lights sounding
eerie overhead other than that the place
is dead quiet
the hall is about a hundred feet along
the two main doors one door opens onto a
large room that looks like a conference
room with a whiteboard and papers strewn
about across the hallway is another door
that looks like a rap oratory of some
sort Dennis slumps against the wall in
defeat and lets out a scary sounding
chuckle something funny I ask is a dark
and brooding panic starts to grip me
Dennis just keeps chuckling as he slides
down to the floor I'm just gonna sit
here while you look around he says
there's a look in his eyes that reminds
me far too much of a dead animal on the
side of the road okay that's weird
so do I enter the conference room of the
lab I feel like the lab might give me
more answers no the lab would just
confuse me I wouldn't know what's going
on the lab but the conference room might
actually have some things that they
whoever was here was disgusting because
I'm just a lumberjack like I was just
here to jack some lumber so best to go
to the conference room and try to get
things in ways that I can understand a
large table sits in the middle of the
room lined with a series of chairs it
looks like something straight out of a
showroom a well-used whiteboard hangs on
the wall and they're scattered papers on
the desks look at the papers look at the
white whiteboard would be the quickest
way to get information a few things are
scribbled on the whiteboard mostly
formulas and names but there are some
things that are easy to understand
things that make my blood go cold
subjects fix causes death embolism or
annuals or both ideas for new delivery
mode spherical liquid induce comatose
state first Terracor Co possible
plutonium supplier let's look at the
papers on the table most of the papers
and printouts of codes and equations
that go way over my head but they're
also handwritten notes that don't make
me feel up any better
situation I read through them and see
scrawled notes that say things like last
experiments failed overdose before
transport levels indicate cellular
catabolism more lead shielding and
export suits measurements make no sense
let Barksdale know about possible Higgs
field fix outside in the hallway I hear
Dennis grunting how do the room to see
him still seated on the floor but I
don't get very far because as I exit a
man comes rushing around the corner with
an automatic rifle in his hands oh [ __ ]
well that's not good well maybe I
shouldn't have shouted that after this
guy started look beyond his rifle but
the man carrying it it's young with
messy dark hair his skin is so pale that
I wonder if he lives down here is the
look of a guy who's been cooped up for a
little too long he doesn't seem to like
the kind of person I trust with a gun in
a stressful situation as he sees us in
the doorway he screams and brings a gun
up it tames directly in my head
Dennis jumps up and stands next to me
like he's ready to run for it I
recognized him by his height and build
he's the person I could barely see back
in the dark hallway put the hands in the
air he's gonna show you you can't close
that distance I put my hands in the air
surprise and how natural feels to go
into this surrendered state maybe it's
because this feels like a dream maybe
it's because I feel like I'll snap awake
at the maniac pulls the trigger who are
you and how did you get here the man
asked harshly before we can answer he
continued speaking I don't recognize you
if you're here you would have had to
sneak by the security mics in the
entrance hall what I asked unable to
think of anything else to say who are
you did you do this
the man eyes that's both and I see
something in his eyes that unsettles me
he's scared but there's something else
we're just loggers we're loggers best to
give them some details his eyes looked
distant for a minute and then he says
[ __ ] but for some reason I'm pretty
sure he knows I'm telling the truth
someone knocked the power out the man
says it's back on now but if it was out
long enough well we're in a heap of
trouble was it you who sent you look we
don't know what you're talking about
something happened out in the woods are
you alone are there others with you the
man asks thrusting the gun in my face
how the hell did we get in this
situation I think to myself if only I
had left that damned ringing noise and
no alone we wouldn't be here I'm not
really sure if we want to give this guy
any information yet we don't know
anything about him then again he might
have answers that still give them a
reason why would we be down here we need
to
rationalize our existence in his mind
we're new to him it's obviously that he
belongs here I don't know why he's alone
down here but we're looking for our crew
we literally came down here looking for
our crew we have other crew members that
we can't find your crew he says confused
if this man thinks that were nuts
there's no telling what he might do the
fact that he looks a little crazy
himself makes a situation even hairier
how'd you get in here I point down the
hall towards the subway we came in that
way the doors weren't locked his
expression calms a bit but I'm still
very aware of the gun that is loved less
than a foot away from my face please put
the gun down no I'm not gonna grab his
gun please don't shoot me
u.s. a man calmly to put his gun down
the only way I'm putting this rifle down
is after I've blown your brains out with
that he fixed the muzzle of the gun in
my face it's a childish move a
playground tactic at best but it's
sufficient to show me that he knows he's
in control now he then levels the rifle
at Dennis and I can only assume it's
because it's wound to make him appear to
be the weaker of us the man takes a
shaky step forward Dennis looks back and
forth between the barrel the gun and me
his eyes pleading for help step between
the dish I'm stepping between that yeah
I'm getting in the way no way before I'm
fully aware of what I'm doing a step out
in front of Dennis the barrel of the
rifle is nearing nearly touching my
chest now both Dennis and the man seem a
little confused at my action and I do my
best to swallow down my fear I don't
know what's going on here but we are
here by mistake well you have no
business here
but now that the power is on I think you
might be too late anyway for what ask
but he doesn't answer me instead he
steps forward and actually pushes me
backwards with the end of its rifle the
man then repeats a question he asks
before one that makes no sense and
honestly makes me think he might be a
little crazy who sent you
you [ __ ] from the Pentagon I'm not
sure how to take this question it's not
joking
best not to be sarcastic no what the
hell are you talking about no we're just
loggers something blew up and my friend
got hurt we're looking for the rest of
our crew likely story but I see a
flicker of recognition in his face that
thinks makes me think he might believe
me still his grip on the gun is as tight
as ever and the look on his face makes
me think he'll shoot at any moment you
both just stand still sooner or later
someone will come along and I'll turn
you over again thrust the gun forward as
if it had him in
invisible bayonet on it there's no need
for that I have no guarantee that he
won't pull the trigger look we don't
want any trouble we're just as confused
as you are then in a movement so fast
that I just about mrs. Dennis lunges
forward I have no idea how he's moving
so fast just 30 seconds ago I was
worried about how close to death he
looked but now that he's moving
lightning fast his left arm coming down
the barrel to gum like a club and the
commotion man does pull the trigger the
booming noise is deafening and there's a
moment where I think I'd better hit it
takes a clanging noise of the round
tearing into the floor my feet to help
me realize that I've not been shot I
look to the floor and see where the shot
missed my right leg by 3 inches I'm
paralyzed
and shocked for a moment as Dennis and
the man fight over possession of the
rifle there's a fire extinguisher on the
wall I could use as a bludgeon but I
NIDA might not have enough time at the
grab aboard Dennis is overpowered No
punch him he's right there punch him on
Jim I'm Jim punch that man then he says
the man pinned to the floor but isn't
strong enough to keep him down as I fall
to the floor to help the barrel the
rifle swings by the back front of my
face and reminder of how close I had
come to being shot on my knees now I
deliver a hard stiff punch to the man's
face I don't punch someone off and never
really not usually the brawling type
still it is apparently effective the
man's head snaps back hard and his grip
on the gun loosens Dennis grabs a gun
and fall to the floor clearly winded and
in pain our attacker is immobilized and
I can feel a shift in the situation yet
although he's basically harmless now I
feel the need to pummel him a desire
that builds with each second I look at
him no no no no no no no no no come on
come on how about one punch is enough
and awesome
this is taken easy he's as stressed as
we are he's definitely out now no threat
at least that's what I think they
surprises me by mustering up one more
swift kick in my direction connecting
with my forehead well I should have had
my hard hat now shouldn't I my eyelids
swell to the size of a grape almost
immediately
seems like this last attack is more to
spite me than to defend himself I
stumbled back and ready myself for
another round of blows but he just
slouches into the floor he's done then
it instantly hands the rifle over to me
and I take it with shaking hands I can't
believe you stepped it between me and
that gun he could have killed you
I was pretty sure he wouldn't I say
although I had no such thing
still thanks man Oh some heroic stuff
you would have done the same right then
it says nothing his eyes look to the
floor what do we do now boss we've come
this far and I want answers I sense the
dentist does too I take a hard look at
the man before I reply we'll get answers
from this guy no answers I don't have
any he said next time I won't just hate
you now get up he obeys quickly but his
legs are wobbly and it leans against the
wall for support I can feel my swollen
eyelid from where he kicked me earlier I
just hope it doesn't get so bad that it
affects my sight okay let's move I have
to say pointing the gun further down the
hallway we've come this far and I'm not
gonna let this guy stop us we walk down
the hallway until we come to an end a
single elevator waits for us it's steel
sliding doors larger than the normal
elevator so that's interesting if I if I
had gone easy on him he hit me in the
eye but if I hadn't gone easy on him
maybe he wouldn't have been able to give
us any answers because he would have
been completely unconscious but at least
now he's awake I don't know if that's a
good thing but I mean we're all in this
together we're obviously not enemies
here well I doesn't look good
better sinister huh boy before I get
into the elevator with this guy I think
it's wise to learn a bit more about him
I can tell he's making him uncomfortable
for me to have a gun what's your name I
asked Marcus and you work here clear
that he doesn't want to answer but he
gives us a little nod we're looking for
the rest of our crew any idea where they
might be no he says currently not
bothering to elaborate got to be some
useful implement we can get out of this
guy I just need to know how to dig for
it
I need a first-aid kit from my friend
here where might I find one down on the
second floor but we can't go down there
what's on level two tell us what's on
level two
it looks at me like I'm an idiot you
must be aware you're inside a classified
government facility he says it makes
sense but I want to doubt it well I'm
sure our government will want you to
help me save my friend so take me to the
first aid kit I can't you don't have
clearance hell I barely have clearance
then seemingly to himself he mutters I
make this place run and not even a thank
you just a bunch of restricted access
rooms that I'm not allowed to go into
with a frickin chaperone go into that
first aid kit I interrupt I could lose
my job I wonder for a moment what sort
of trouble I could get him in for
hitting a government employee which
makes me glad I took it easy on him then
again he had come at us with a rifle
makes me think things gone terribly
wrong in this place and the explosion in
the woods whatever the hell happened
might be linked to it all I need to
convince him to take us to the second
floor but I'm not sure if it would be
more productive to threaten him or ask
for sympathy
well threatening him might work but he's
obviously scared we obviously have a gun
I don't even know if sympathy would work
on this guy he seems really really
high-strung and seem to lose seemingly
okay from the little bit that I've seen
of him he seems like a guy that takes
his job very seriously even though he
feels like he's been unappreciative
so maybe threatening him would be the
more direct way but also once he
realizes who we are and that we actually
are saying who we are threatening him
might not be the best option so we could
just literally ask we are in trouble if
this doesn't work then I know he's not
gonna work look hasn't been the best day
we're just trying to find out what's
going on to find a crew to survive I
know that this isn't a normal situation
down here it looks like all your
protocols have been blown to hell can't
you help us out he looks at me sternly
weighing his options okay thank you I
say with an untrusting stare Marcus
walks to the elevator door approaching a
small keypad by the doors he punches in
the numerical code on the keypad we hear
a slight mechanical hum behind the steel
doors after a few seconds of angry
glances and frightened sneers from
markets the elevator arrives the steel
doors slide open with a whisper
revealing the interior well
going down apparently asking nicely does
work occasionally even though it gets a
punched in the face maybe that wouldn't
have worked if I had pummeled him maybe
you would have been left behind if I
pummeled it it's exceptionally well lit
and looks to be made of stainless steel
a half expected thing to take off at the
speed of light there's another small
keypad on the front right panel by the
door with the options of three sublevel
four it looks like this elevator doesn't
go to the surface so after we get a
first aid kit for Dennis how do we get
out of here
we can't leave once the power comes back
on the whole place was put on lockdown
what can't you override it no it's to
prevent anything from getting out I
can't
Marcus looks as deflated as Dennis we
can't get out we're stuck here
Dennis leans into the corner and almost
falls onto the floor the struggle for
the rifle really took a lot out of him I
can see that much on its face slowly we
start to move down the hum and grind of
the cars motor skills and space let's
not be hopeless about it we're not stuck
here forever
yeah but what can you do is a little
antagonistic it's all just as he if I
say we're stuck here forever he might
actually give us more information be
like no it's stupid so we're stuck here
forever
Marcus scowled at me I think it's a fair
question doesn't seem unreasonable to
assume he won't be able to help us get
out we'll find somebody with access
codes and they'll be begging me to
figure out how to lift the lockdown see
little information these people think
they're so brilliant but some of them
can barely turn their computers on
without help the top coder in my class
at MIT and I'm stuck living underground
helping idiots who don't even trust me
with keys god he's spilling information
spilling it spilling it out what goes on
here might be a bit too direct because
because he takes his job very seriously
he's very intelligent individual he's
very top coder in his classes MIT so if
I keep asking them what goes on here he
might think that I'm like getting in
there so I'm gonna ask how big the place
is which is a fair question it's a
government facility of the highest
secrecy a research facility goes four
stories underground and quite frankly it
scares the piss out of me that you two
got in here so easily why is that I
asked this is a black ops graveyard even
the CIA doesn't know this place exists
okay yeah so yeah what goes on here I'm
thinking that's like if I ask that he's
not going to tell me so what's his job
he'd probably be willing to talk about
that I handled the IT work and make sure
the day
bases are up and running it's a 24/7 job
I haven't seen sunlight in almost a year
I wonder what staying in a place like
this does for that long would do that
someone's minded I was recruited because
of the workload no one else wants this
job and I don't really mind being by
myself no family plus CIT some crazy
[ __ ] crazy how this place generates over
100 terabytes of data per day the
answers getting the slightest bit
excited before his face falls again what
happened here I think that's a fair
question
what happened just literally what
happened and maybe more specifically
what knocked the lights out both are
like the same question seems like some
sort of power outage that's all I know
there was an outage in Venice and what
been assessed weekly then things got
weird things got bad bad how the whole
place seems to shake when the lights
went out I was checking the monitors
when it happened and everything went
dead it took no more than a minute or so
before I started hearing screams people
were being killed by something I tried
getting the security cameras going again
but they only lasted for a little bit on
my backup systems what I saw what I
asked feeling a sharp fear one its way
into my guts what I saw on the screens
for a little bit of time made no sense
made me get the done from the emergency
ball I think whatever it is it's still
down here hold on there's an emergency
ball with a rifle in the same room as
security cameras in this place Marcus
give me a grin that looks nearly insane
their guns locked away in every room in
this place just in case you know just in
case of what I think we all know what
just in case of what but so we're still
in danger here if he opens his mouth to
answer the elevator comes to a stop and
the door slides open Marcus is out right
away without a word he makes his exit
and heads directly for a glassed-in room
that's filled with computer monitors and
high-end equipment I bet he's going to
get a gun
Dennis and I file in behind them trying
to keep up but as we do one very
alarming question runs through my head
how kind of government facility keeps
loaded gun in emergency vaults in every
single room excellent question and a
question that we will not find out in
this episode but possibly in another so
let's find out our stats that I deviated
from the norm a bit you and 58% of
players called out to Marcus when you
saw him in the tunnel oh okay
selflessness you and 64% of players
stepped in front of
Janice to protect him from Marcus you
and 65% of players were easy on Marcus
after he surrendered well that's not bad
that's not bad at all I did pretty good
there I mean I did what the popular
opinion was but apparently that's that's
okay
so I'm actually surprised that that many
people called out to Marcus but either
way that is the end of chapter two if
you want to play this game for yourself
and discover some other like secrets I
want to know how branching this story is
because there's a lot of choices to be
made here so just let me know down in
the comments below what you guys can do
the game they'll be in the description I
think there's like three dollars on
Steam it might be on sales what's up
right good let me know so thanks again
everybody for watching as always I will
see you in the next video bye
[Music]